welcome into this video 15-minute chess
again here on icc you DSA DSA double
v.v.v ok the Trump offski and yeah the
Trump of scheme I play this nightie 45
line very solid stuff there is more
exciting there are more exciting lines
but I really don't know them so I'm
sticking with what I actually do know
maybe is playing with foi o ok this is
justice excite more exciting ok
okay it's taking hmm interesting that's
not very expected ready hmm thinking if
I've but what is this the capture is six
probably just getting the pawn back well
I guess um let's let's play it like that
simple chairs
hmm you can try before but if I could
have taken a form by the way anyway but
I don't I don't want to spoil my
castling rights really and if I just get
c5 back the big issue here is that the
move f3 is really really ugly why does
what center is largely unsupported and
I'm not totally sure how he intends to
to continue here Jim before looks really
wacky
hmm what do we had position I don't know
well maybe just still be five if we are
he goes for that makes the bishop on f4
look a little bit funny but probably
probably and there's nothing else I
don't know okay well I get c5 and I mean
before this even knight c6 double
attacking be for 95 96 okay there is
also an interesting idea f6 if he takes
Queen takes this double check on the
rook and the bishop but ok let's just
double attack be 45 getting one porn
back in the process
okay so if i take it with the denied i
wonder if i can take it with the d7
night takes and b5 then I g6 I cannot do
that yeah takes be five notches 6b takes
c6 night except for Queen a phone that's
not good I wait but I can check on on on
edge for kingdom one Wow King be one
maybe b5 as a move Wow come on that's
just let's just keep it simple maybe
deep net D takes d5 was stronger but I
don't really want to miscalculate and
lose a quick game okay um just drop this
back here
so we have equal material yes he has
supported those those pawns and how do i
play the snow just castling or I mean
preparing to Castle we should be sub
probably sm there should be seven and
castles I need to get out of this is
weird pin here okay that position is not
so bad for a white thinking of Bishop d7
Leah trying to treat this LightSquared
bishops because the light squares are
somewhat sensitive in in white some camp
after he has put those pawns on dark
squares c 3 c 5 and before
another idea might be at something like
a five to take on before cb4 and then e
five and deform try to get better
central control okay
this looks loose somehow I don't really
now I cannot really exploited I don't
know there's no I'm no tactic or
anything let's just see to get this
Bishop on CA traded or developed but not
I don't want to have it on CSC ate all
the time um my original idea was to play
night if fire but no yes Bishop e2 or
Bishop see tool I can go I five maybe
five yeah let's just grab the center
after night g6 hd6 i also have Bishop f5
maybe to get the bishop out or traded
mm yeah I wonder see really intending to
retreat and sister looks very weird
let's know he does he does not retreat
okay grabbing here I also wonder still
wonder about this a 5 possibility an
Audi force also move d 4 takes 95
exploiting this new bishop and attacking
unknown on before it's probably not bad
for me d 4 takes 95 bishop f 2 night
before Bishop b4 something like this
yeah but am I am I better in this
position who not clear stem thing though
let's do it I can also just take on
deform but then he might cover the whole
thing with a three I had the whole thing
I mean before I can must be form
yeah I just I just expect Bishop f2
covering the bishop looks weird ok so
now take here yeah let's take it we
should be for its really really possible
but maybe just Bishop c6 now push ups
e61 well can take you five I take G for
Bishop e7 rook p8 yeah why not yeah c5
hang so should be possible Bishop e7
would be eight for a tempo and then
Bishop c5 that's a pawn and Bishop takes
d4 is just comfortable for black or
better I don't know maybe it's more than
comfortable but yeah ok I think this was
was pretty much forced but now how does
he avoid the loss of the pawn and maybe
he gets it back with night b3m or
something like that just Bishop b4
Bishop takes d5 and night be three I
would have Bishop a4 maybe to keep the
pawn ok
that seems viable and what exactly is he
now thinking about is there an
alternative to Bishop you form this it
seems but this is also porn right night
cheeks I take it with the night Bishop a
six yeah I mean if I take it he has to
go Bishop a six or give me I gives me
the bishop pair okay in a wide open
position this this looks very nice now
do you three yes nikon this must be
right
is this bishop this should win really
unless I'm i can play 94 year I have to
Bishop b5 just covering d3 I should have
thought about it at least a moment
please for a moment hmm okay I wait the
the bishop the pole is not really
hanging due to Bishop b5 tactic the pawn
is not really hanging so i can actually
move the bishop if i want but it's there
a good spot for it
27 and then Bishop b5 maybe 27 I can
actually take c6 you should be seven
looks really really stupid
at least that keeps the bishop our
Bishop d7 maybe a rook to be 6 intending
Bishop b5
if I go Bishop b5 look be one and a six
or something adds that that's really
really looking strange but Queen d5 is
amazing I can do that would be 125 is
still ok Wow weird stuff yeah yeah yeahs
here I just thought okay let's give up
the exchange why not the pawn is very
very strong but i wonder how to give up
the exchange exactly or bishop f6 by the
way
okay let's put it here or to see foreign
okay let's go here maybe I should have
played it all totally differently so
also move like whoopsie one him okay
Bishop b3 FK it's not a problem okay so
it probably should just take on be eight
no it's not taking them okay that's
strange I mean the pawn was dangerous
but I mean it's still dangerous I'm not
and I'm not an exchange down now it's
really weird
hmm this should be really really good
now right Bishop to b4 preparing the to
push rookie 425 no who 25-34 lacking can
always go to a six and still have d to
look to you for now there's also bishops
III now at the point comes to d2 it is
really it's really too much
Bishop's III I guess one to 290 they can
take with the e rogue poo okay okay it
really should be enough
VA droopy aids there any way you can
catch the pawn oh and don't see it
ruki three that's at least rope t8 but
probably there is a more forceful way to
finish this this is a self pena I can
take cat and Queen B 6 rook takes Queen
B 6 route 23 route d8 yeah he should
have taken the exchange I was somehow
struggling around my sister's eyes yeah
Luke chicks can be 6 23 or up da twins a
look yeah he should take the exchange
really here with this I go here and now
he simply didn't take it let's let's
have a look i mean i think i have very a
decent compensation but he must try that
computer actually assesses this as as a
win for black yeah I wasn't completely
sure but the computer basically confirms
that i can get in bishop before he r and
d to all the time and if i manage that
are in the exchange is totally
irrelevant I thought maybe a move like
this but this is like yeah I mean this
is I ok yeah I was a bit too pessimistic
here uncharacteristically for me but it
still is better for him to play that
instead of this here here I'm just
winning us black coming there is no way
around that yeah yeah let's let's have a
brief look at the opening phase of the
game it was really a strange opening
here and went here here f6 was was a
funny idea also
with this with this plan but okay this
is not bad he went c3 ok ok ok I have 85
yes a5 is even stronger I was wasting
lots of time with this calculation but I
thought ultimately then this is a
problem but Queen f6 is strong I had
calculated this this line s alright then
King d1 and I have this that'sthat's
cute yeah especially nice is that check
this check is answered with a counter
check so it's not even getting the
rookie in the corner yeah what do we had
line okay I I just took it at the end
and I this way have not gained the are
not gotten the best possible outcome
from the opening I'm okay here but
nothing serious interesting the computer
gives this is excellent for from black
yeah yeah that's true that's really true
that's very good for black the thing is
he has to take check and then after a 5
i'm completely completely destroying the
queenside it's still impossible to cover
the whole thing because of this and
black is just winning mmm nice it was
much better okay and now this deform
wolffian
computer this is on 000 yeah so there is
some some sort of reply yeah yeah there
is a reply but not a very human one the
computer now gives the the funky move
Bishop g6 okay queen bee three check is
the point and after he takes d4 Bishop
g4 Bishop c6 the computer computer
assesses the position as about equal
okay this is what he played takes takes
and he I'm better am a three is better
mighty 6a here for the bishop a 6 but
here i probably have simpler moves
instead of this yeah it is simpler to
attack the look here by far look you one
and then then d 3 this makes the whole
business much easier here yeah 94 m it
took me a while to to understand that i
can give up the exchange but it
ultimately was okay okay hope you
enjoyed this rabid game thanks for
watching